let's start today with the growing chaos
omits the Trump White House staff we
followed individually a lot of these
firings and resignations and a number of
them actually happened during our
vacation that I haven't even gotten a
chance to talk with you about so to
catch you up we saw in no particular
order the forced resignation of
disgraced national security adviser
Michael Flynn
we saw the firing of director of White
House communications Anthony scaramouche
II just a few days after officially
starting his role there no replacement
the interim replacement is hope Hicks
although there's no official actual
long-term director of White House
communications right now former chief of
staff Prince Priebus is out
Reince Priebus I'm sorry replaced by
John Kelly as chief chief of staff no
plans right now to fill the role of
chief strategist left open by the
disappearance of Breitbart propagandist
Steven Bannon during our vacation Sean
Spicer White House press secretary he
left replaced by Sarah Huckabee Sanders
former chief of staff Reince Priebus 'as
deputy named Katie Walsh left the
administration months ago months ago
made less of a splash Boris Epstein
another adviser fired back in March and
then at lower levels that there's a lot
of other staffers who have been let go
communication aid Michael shorts
communication aide Andrew hemming
they're also not being immediately
replaced and there's way more that we
haven't even heard of and not and in
addition to that there's many positions
that have just never been filled to
begin with and then we saw this sort of
capped off near the end of our vacation
with the removal of Sebastian Gorka
who's a Steve ban and Ally who was
deputy assistant to the president has
horrific white nationalist white
supremacist ties which we've talked
about and there's a few different layers
to this number one recruiting is
probably kind of difficult right now in
the Trump White House you've got
multiple investigations who would want
to join this administration right now
particularly when it's not even really
clear how long it's going to last and
then you've got the new chief of staff
John Kelly
every indication is that he's a big
factor in what's been going on here and
there's actually an interesting article
from earlier today in Politico which
says quote interviews with six White
House staffers and people close to the
president attribute Trump's shrinking
west wing to three factors chief of
staff John Kelly's careful review
process which has led to the paring down
of an organization that many inside of
complained was top-heavy
the chilling factor of five open-ended
Russia investigations hanging over the
White House making it hard to attract
new talent and the president's own dark
mood this summer which has left him
increasingly isolated and in the mood to
hunker down and not higher up this
strategy that we're learning about from
the new chief of staff John Kelly
I guess he's considering a system where
the only people directly reporting to
the president would be the chief of
staff himself John Kelly the staff
secretary and the White House Counsel no
one else would directly report to the
president and this does a few things
number one it sort of eliminates the
space for someone in a Steve ban and
strategy position to directly influence
the president's thinking if you're John
Kelly and you're even remotely sensible
you're going to try to put distance
between Trump and the people that get
him to do really crazy stuff so that
makes sense but also the isolation of
Trump Trump seems to from an emotional
standpoint from everything we know
really not be doing well and watching TV
for hours on end in the Oval Office and
reducing the number of people that
report directly to the president it
could be part of a strategy from Kelly
to prevent Trump from doing crazy stuff
but it could also make Trump go into an
even darker place and that might have
been a big reason as to why Anthony
scaramouche II was ousted absolutely he
wanted to report directly to the
president and communications director
and circumvents the chief of staff and
what also is interesting is that there
used to be these three segments of the
Trump cabinet there was the
establishment segment or a branded by
Reince Priebus there was the white
nationalist segment represents
by steve Bannon and then there was the
military generals like Sean Kelly and
Jim mattis and it seems like the latter
has won out that it's going to be you
know the the rule of the the military in
this cabinet you can expect him to
become a lot more hawkish and I think
that's why we see him stepping up his
game when it comes to Afghanistan in
particular and that's been a concern I
mean very early on when we first got the
list remember Pat of who it was that
Trump was considering for secretary
positions and advisory positions one of
the first things I said was it seems
very military heavy and I outlined a
variety of reasons why that is something
that we should be concerned about
there is almost no establishment wing
left in the Trump administration you
could kind of say Jeff Sessions is the
most prominent link to establishment
Republicans that is left right now and
it's been pretty damn dicey for Jeff
sessions over time one other thought on
this if you are a small government
conservative you want fewer government
employees you want government to be as
small as possible so maybe you see what
is total disarray in the Trump White
House and you say hey this is good
because I want small government but I
want to make another point if you don't
want Trump accomplishing things maybe
you also want less staff because the
less the the the smaller Trump staff is
maybe the more difficult it is for him
to actually get things done and we don't
want Trump doing things because
everything he wants to do is a disaster
even from the beginning he had a tough
time filling the vacancies in the West
Wing yeah right getting a confirmation
from the Senate and now that problem is
exacerbated in part because I think a
lot of people have these distinguished
careers and their relative in their
respective fields and they don't want to
leave such lucrative positions only to
be fired within like a week or a month
or to have your reputation absolutely
destroyed the way happened to Sean
Spicer press secretary yeah I think I
think that that's absolutely valid and
will continue to see how far this goes
and how pared down the Trump staff
becomes the video you just finished
watching was made possible by you
through the membership program you can
sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17
for a 40% discount off of your
membership